jubilee presenta reunimos a siete
parejas somos una pareja una pareja una
es falsa si el grupo descubre quiénes
son los mentirosos se repartirán un
premio en efectivo
si se quedan ganarán todo el premio el
impostor temporada 3 episodio 2 saben
los nombres de sus padres nació y kerry
y su madre esta vida y su padre es peter
carmen y patricia david y terry todos
dicen nombres de padres pero no sé cómo
se llaman sus padres podrían estar
inventando nombres por lo que no me
dijiste los nombres de tus padres y creo
que yo tampoco conocieron a los padres
del otro o saben los nombres solo
pasados seis meses supongo pero como sea
es necesario dijeron que llevaban seis
meses juntos y pensé yo deberían conocer
los nombres de sus madres hablen de
su peor pelea hay algo que quieran de
ella dijo mucha hierba la nuestra
siento que es porque de los dos
trabajamos mucho los dos trabajamos en
el cine siento que los momentos más
oscuros recuerdos son bien porque no me
gustó algo que hiciste o estaba
deprimido por algo y tú me preguntas qué
me pasa algo así
mis padres no son son difíciles no lo
siento
hagámoslo del aniversario creo que todos
lo hemos olvidado que digan los mismo
tiempos y 28 de septiembre el 28 de
septiembre de junio primera ronda
votos de los seguidores quién es el
impostor
y
[Música]
no sabían los nombres de sus padres
i
fuimos los únicos de todos ellos que no
sabíamos así que todos estaban como
podemos hablar de cuando se dieron
cuenta de que se gustaban que qué fue lo
que les hizo sentir algo ella solía
venir a un bar que yo dirigía y la
molestaba porque no parecía tener 21
años yo la perseguía y no era su tipo al
principio pero definitivamente no era mi
tipo salí con atletas negros toda mi
vida yo estaba interesada en ti y yo no
quería que yo
no quería ser como yo ya estamos
trabajando juntos pero vamos a hacer
esto y esto pero podemos salir no quería
que hemos terminado entienden si fue la
orientación el primer año estaba en
segundo año siguen y amigos y ella era
de primer año éramos los mejores amigos
teníamos
y tú lo sabías desde antes y yo siempre
supe que me gustaba bajar y ella no lo
supo como hasta dos años después cuando
tuvimos una fiesta de ella vimos una
pijamada y si ya saben luego empezamos a
salir lo físico está fuera de los
límites no no lo está besarse
si un pequeño beso rápido todos
por qué
[Risas]
justo antes del beso él dijo está bien y
yo dije por qué dirías por qué dijiste
eso antes de besar pensé en eso parece
sospechoso
bien cuál es la cita más romántica que
han tenido nos fuimos de viaje a los
pocos meses al norte y nos quedamos en
una cabaña fuimos de excursión en
redwood sí y fue muy relajante aunque
eso fue cuando quería decir te amo y tú
lo hiciste
una semana
[Risas]
todos se toman de las manos no es como
sabes o algo así
sí
[Música]
i
vaya
me pregunto por qué
[Risas]
tienen anillos no los trajimos porque
pensamos y entendimos mal
puede pasar
felicidad si estaba embarazada pero eso
no significa que sea su bebé podría ser
el bebé de cualquiera porque no se puede
ser mente la excusa perfecta algo que
cada uno sabría del otro por la
intimidad como gestos raros o algo así
él me obliga a usar el hilo dental ya
cepillarme los dientes siempre yo puedo
estar arropada en la cama y el eso es
malo no es que él me obliga es decir es
algo bueno enlace la cosa más asquerosa
se hurga los dedos de los pies y luego
se muerde las uñas
y eso es asqueroso porque intenta
besarme después solo experto dígase algo
profundo
quiero ver algo miren a los ojos soy muy
agradecida por lo mucho que has crecido
desde que tú y yo empezamos a salir
porque sé qué
tu ansiedad te limitaba en muchas cosas
pero ahora no estoy muy orgullosa de ti
ahora estoy agradecido porque me motiva
hacer cosas como esta que me ayudan a
crecer estás llevando a mi hijo dentro
de ti y eso es una experiencia increíble
y nunca habría elegido a nadie más estoy
muy feliz de que podamos hacer cosas
juntos creo que al conocerte durante
estos 16 años he crecido mucho como
mujer y tú has tenido un papel enorme en
ese crecimiento te amo no sé por qué
estoy aquí soy una persona muy ansiosa
pero tú me haces muy feliz también soy
nervioso pero me alegro de que no sé que
tenemos a salir por eso me enamoré de ti
estoy agradecido de estar aquí y sabes
que eres mi mejor amigo y me alegro de
todo lo que hemos hecho juntos y estoy
emocionado de ver lo que podemos hacer
mientras esté contigo cielo conquistar
todo pase lo que pase juntos cariño
sabes que te adoro tú sacaste lo mejor
de mí
eres el mejor bien siento que te digo
esto todo el tiempo pero si no
estuvieras conmigo no se quería
abandonaría la escuela y me iría tú me
motiva y me enfocas creo que no importa
dónde estés si estoy contigo soy feliz
tú eres mi mejor amiga y sé que
estaremos bien sin importar lo que
hagamos te amo estaré muy molestas si
alguien aquí está bien ya venimos nos
pregunta si los haces y lo mejor me
siento bien con todos aquí dentro es muy
tarde
[Música]
ah
bien
somos personas muy reservadas es
incómodo para nosotros estar con la creo
que ellos pensaron que no éramos
genuinos cuando hablábamos levanten la
mano si tienen dudas y podremos
continuar con el juego
muy bien este es el final del juego si
las luces se vuelven verdes expulsados
mentiras y las luces se vuelven rojas el
mentiroso sigue en la caca y pierden
no sabían
traigamos a todos los de vuelta
bien los infiltrados pueden rebelarse
estoy indignado
los universitarios pensaron que pensaba
que había ido muy lejos en la parte del
beso sentía que fue muy intenso y
después de que la actuaron bien si
actuaron bien lo reconozco cuando
contaron su historia sobre la exposición
de arte creo que todos lo creímos
[Risas]
tuve una sospecha cuando empezamos
porque era como algo paz podrían ser muy
buenas amigas pero lo descarte por
completo debí haber seguido mi instinto
parecía más un espectáculo que una
conexión genuina en cuanto a pareja se
refiere parecía más una amistad que una
verdadera relación amorosa si es difícil
cuando la gente está diciendo si nos
amamos decir no lo hacen
sí sí sí sí es paya baní vamos a ir a un
spa después de esto jubilee vive
intensamente